if brexit we say was about taking back
control the government has taken back
control of its borders of the
immigration system but it has decided to
certain for certain groups at least you
know turn on the Taps and there are good
economic reasons for this you know we
have still have over a million vacancies
in the job market a huge proportion of
the increase in worker visas is for
people working in the NHS and social
care these are jobs that need to be
filled in so the government cannot
really claim that this is something they
don't have control over there there's
just there's a an economic case for
migration that they have chosen to
accept now of course people might say
there are you know cultural reasons why
do you still want to curb this number
but it's a balance between that and the
the economics and clearly the government
is going with the economic argument for
you know letting more and more workers
into the economy